hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
edition of ask Evan today mention a
question from one of my readers Michael
who knew my sister n and brother-in-law
and has a website called burn the couch
and one of my advice on what to do about
it so let's load up the website here and
see what kind of advice we can give for
or Michael so we got it here is the
website okay so great Bruce competitions
club our competitors club engaging
community through competitions so he
specifically wrote insane I don't know
if I have a proper call to action or if
I don't have a clearly defined why so
look in this website engaging the
community through competition so I by
looking this my thought is you're trying
to get people together have some fun
have some competition I would think
about what is the Y so you talked about
the Y engaging the community it explains
what you do but there's no heart behind
it right it may be something like get to
know your neighbors alright that may be
a better way to explain what it is that
you do so get to know your neighbors
through competition it just is more
friendly and inviting than engaging the
community sounds like a corporate slogan
that a big company would have and
doesn't have any heart to it so you
might want to switch that up a little
bit and looking at this you know value
proposition here what is a competitor's
club and we summed up in one simple
phrase reality shows portray reality we
created that I think could definitely
use some work have you ever watched
rarely shown today and set yourself a
wish I could do that or sit on the panel
judges I'm not sure this is your this is
the value proposition I don't think too
many people look at a reality show and
say I could do that I think the the
benefit of doing joining up with your
community here is to get to know your
neighbors to do something active which
ties into your website burn the couch
right why we called burn the couch
because you're gonna get off your feet
and go
go do something hopefully that's why the
name is burn the couch you want to have
fun and maybe not tease not spend a lot
of money right if you're entering these
kind of challenges then it's something
fun to do with your community get to
know your neighbors and not have to
spend a lot of money doing it I think if
you had those pawns points and more come
more front and center you'd attract a
lot more people and be able to quickly
explain the benefits of joining up then
then this where I'm not sure people
would really twig to this kind of stuff
the next I want to look at is a slightly
better design on the site it's okay um
you know like the borders and stuff
around the pictures here but you could
if you're on a wordpress theme you could
easily get a slightly better wordpress
design or look at places like 99 designs
just to spruce up the the website a
little bit maybe show something about
the community like a big picture of
people having fun that's why they're
gonna sign up for this is they want to
have fun and get to know their neighbors
so have a big picture people having fun
like what is it like to do one of these
competitions and those pictures with
emotion and people you know express it
how much fun they're having will make
people want to sign up right where if
you just selling it through text it's a
lot harder to convey the same message so
let's look at your events 90-day
weight-loss challenge let's see what
this one is all about as it slowly loads
so contestants for 90-day weight-loss
challenge so this is great that we can
see who's involved here I would want to
see where people started so like what do
you win for for doing it what are the
starting weights of people what are they
at now and see who's kind of on the
leaderboard it's great to see the people
involved this is this is what I think is
the whole point is to get to know the
people around the community a little bit
better
but there's no updates on how they're
doing so I definitely want to include
that information in there but I'd also
also want to see pictures of people
having fun on every every page in
contests that you have I think you could
do a lot of work mostly they'll bond
that home page in that value proposition
like we already talked about honestly
though I think your best bet is going to
be local this is a local campaign and as
much as I love the web and as much as
people will visit your website I'd see
it more as a as a online flyer so people
who you talk to locally would then go to
your website and hopefully sign up but I
would design specific campaign so maybe
it's this easter egg drop challenge or
it's a weight loss challenge and go
local make partnerships and do flyer
drops around your area and it's also you
getting to know your neighbors right you
go knock on doors meet people tell them
about what you're doing show them
pictures of people having fun and try to
get them signed up and the website can
complement that but I don't think it's
gonna be your main marketing tool at
least not yet at least at the beginning
do a local campaign get people signed up
email them with updates on whatever the
next competition is I wasn't clear what
your business model is here or if there
is a business model maybe this is just
something to do to have fun maybe you're
gonna get sponsors from companies who
want to want to market to you know local
people maybe you're going to charge for
the membership I know right now it's
free maybe you're still trying to figure
it out or maybe there is no what model
you just you just want to do it to help
your community but that was a long clear
from looking at the website so i hope
that helps michael i'm really interested
initiative i I think there's a lot of
value here I almost wish there something
like this where I lived I would probably
sign up and get involved so I think you
have something strong I think people
don't know their neighbors enough we're
so you know tied up in what we're doing
in our day-to-day lives that we often
don't take the time to get to know our
community and doing something like this
could be a fun way to do it and so you
know if I if I see a need for it in my
community I'm sure other people will
around where you are as well but just
explaining it better you know I
want to sign up because I wish I could
be part of a reality show or I wish I
could judge 1i sent up to do something
fun on the weekend it's not gonna cost
me a lot of money you know get out out
of the house get off my couch and get to
meet some of the people who who are live
with so a lot of opportunity I hope you
can make some of those changes and keep
us posted on how you're doing so thanks
for the question Michael for those of
you watching if you liked the video
please give it a thumbs up below makes
gonna do more for you and if you have a
comment about this video or a question
for your own business feel free to leave
it in the comments section on youtube I
always check those I love seeing them I
always makes my day when new comments
come in so thank you and I'll see you on
the next episode
you
you
you